right justin fields the guy who was the
favorite as of a week ago to be that
third overall pick
a report emerged yesterday from nfl
media and i'm gonna pontificate in a
second or two not that anyone cares
about
nfl media reporting this
stuff out even if teams know about it
justin fields has informed teams that he
has epilepsy
he hasn't been affected by the condition
on the field
symptoms have been less frequent in
recent years other members of his family
have outgrown the condition in their 20s
doctors believe that could be the case
for fields as well i i just i
look i i i don't know where the line is
when it comes to putting this stuff out
there for public consumption the teams
already know though
so it's not like it's going to hurt him
right on draft
that's right i could explain if he
slides it could help explain it
um i just it just it there's just
something about it that bugs me
when when stuff like this gets out and
and it's a shame
that people's private medical condition
becomes subject for public discussion
and transaction and speculation
but i guess the argument would be it
goes with the territory when you're
going to play a game that that your
availability
on sunday is a major aspect of your
desirability
to be drafted then you you kind of open
that door and the fact that fields
advise teams of that on his own would
make it even more appropriate i suppose
for it to be leaked and discussed
there's just something about it that
that that doesn't sit right with me
chris am i wrong no i mean you're you're
not wrong i mean you know again it's
uh it is privacy of a player it is a
medical issue
and really what i would really say more
than anything too
is it just seems more like
propaganda piling on justin fields to me
which i don't like and listen i know i'm
not the biggest fan of justin fields the
player and i've been one of those guys
to say i don't think he's a top 10 pick
that doesn't mean anything about the
person or the guy i've seen
i mean i'm i i hope he proves me wrong
but that's to me where i go wait okay so
he let everybody know you have epilepsy
has he missed a game
or we've heard anything over the last
two years that has affected him in his
preparation for ohio state
absolutely not we have not okay so
just leave it at that it just seems like
a little bit piling on a guy to me
at this point and i think that's what
kind of bothers me my best friend in
college
was epileptic he played on the football
team roderick babers
right he yeah had to deal with it it was
a pain in the butt
a little but it never affected his play
or anything like that
you know it came about sometimes when he
was stressed out or
tired or things like that but he managed
it he did
you know we had a few scares every now
and then we'd be sitting there playing
epilep
uh i mean xbox and you know he would
have a seizure and you know
it we'd be all freaked out or whatever
else and try to help him and do all that
type of stuff but
you know i think this sounds like
something that's he's got under control
and i don't see it affecting his play or
anything like that as we go on here
ohio state coach ryan day who came out a
couple of weeks ago when issues emerged
about justin fields commitment to the
game love of the game etc
tweeted yesterday justin's health
toughness and work ethic have never been
an issue and i'm incredibly proud of his
professionalism and the character he
displays on and off the field
yeah the fact that he never missed a
game at ohio state speaks volumes about
how he takes care of himself
the good news this time around ryan day
didn't use that opportunity to
speak slander other people last year
yeah yeah he's
found the right balance when it comes to
supporting his players but
look there's
i've been doing this 20 years now it
doesn't just
fall out of the sky randomly when
reporters
get this information a week before the
draft
someone who knows it and someone who
should be protecting it even if all 32
teams know it you know
all 32 teams know the wonderlic scores
but that doesn't stop someone with an
agenda
from leaking the bad ones or in this
case someone
with an agenda leaking the justin fields
acknowledged that he has epilepsy
that's what bothers me about it because
somebody's up to something
in putting this out and all too often we
in the media and specifically the nfl
which has its own media conglomerate
is willing to soak that up and
spit it all back out into the world
under the guise of doing what the media
is supposed to do yeah
that's what bothers me because they're
trafficking in
medical information that should be
private and i know i know there's a
public nature to being an nfl
quarterback and again all 32 teams know
about it but what bothers me chris is i
feel like
someone for whatever reason yeah wanted
this to get out
a week before the draft yeah or yeah i i
i don't disagree
want to get it out or more to me that it
jumps out i would say from my stance to
just going
somebody who's just real thirsty and
hungry to get attention by putting
something out
like i again i have information i talk
to people in the nfl you know that i got
friends i know some of these guys
wonderlic scores and all those things
you know we just talk about football and
it's oh hey did you know yeah well he
tested this way or he did this and
you know you're just talking about the
guy and yeah i know some of these things
about these players behind the scenes
but i don't i'm not sitting here trying
to
you know board it out to the public or
do anything like that
uh so yeah i think it's one probably
maybe intended to
also somebody in the media is just like
wait oh wait you were we were talking
about justin fields and
you know the guy brought up you know the
the area scouter hey you know he's
epileptic too that's another thing
that's to worry about and
you know now that reporters hey nobody's
put that out there and they're they're
thirsty to get that out there and get
the attention and everything like that
that way too
so um yeah it bothers me a little too
mike i'm with you there's no doubt about
it
um but i don't think it's gonna be a
game changer as far as
his draft stock him dropping or anything
like that
you know in a week from now yeah
but i think we've hit the nail on the
head there's just something about it
that just
it's it's it's a tough call and and i i
i fear that the people who traffick in
this from a media standpoint
never bother to stop and think is this
what i should be doing right just do it
because there's that constant pressure
be first
get information have something someone
doesn't else someone else doesn't have
and you never stop and think whether
it's something that you shouldn't i've
been there i've done it i've learned
i've grown over the years i
listen we used to put out the wonderlic
numbers we don't anymore and if
something like this had fallen into my
lap i'd like to think that i would have
said you know what i'm not comfortable
reporting this
let someone else do it but i'm not going
to yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports